hey guys and welcome back to the channel
so today we are going to be talking
about hbase which is a database that is
built on top of Hadoop so this is going
to be a quick diversion off of the
course of talking about batch processing
uh which we're going to be doing right
after this since you know now we're
starting to get into all of that fun
stuff
um and even though there's plenty to
cover there let's go ahead and get
started by talking about hbase I've got
to get into the gym after this because I
ate a ton of deep dish pizza this
weekend and I ruined my cut so let's get
into it and I will see you on the iPad
alright so assuming that you're not a
phony you've obviously watched last
video about Hadoop uh but considering
that most you are phonies you probably
haven't so in that case uh let's do a
quick recap and say that hdfs or Hadoop
distributed file system is effectively
just a distributed way of storing a
bunch of different files in a manner
that is Fault tolerant redundant all
that good stuff but the issue with it is
something that we're going to talk about
which is that when we actually have a
file stored and we want to make a
modification to it it's very inefficient
so here's an example of a file right
here in Hadoop and as you can see we've
got some information let's think of this
as a key Value Store where we've got all
of our attractiveness levels of some
common characters that we're all
familiar with as you can see Jordan 10
out of 10 as expected but the issue is
let's go ahead and say that Elon after
uh you know limiting the amount of
Twitter posts that we can see has now
become a 5 out of 10. well in Hadoop at
least there's no way that we can just go
ahead and make an ad hoc edit to just
one file at a time and edit one piece of
data on disk in fact we would have to
overwrite being entire file and in
reality these files aren't just going to
be four lines long they're going to be
many many megabytes and as a result of
that doing such an operation is
extremely expensive especially when you
have to consider Network and replication
costs so in reality if we are operating
a Hadoop cluster and we want to be able
to take the data that we already have
and modify it just using vanilla hdfs
probably isn't a great solution unless
we plan on overwriting files all the
time which like I said is going to be
slow and expensive
so this is going to segue us into hbase
where hbase is effectively a database
that we've built on top of Hadoop and by
we I mean a bunch of rando nerds on the
internet and so number one is that hbase
is going to allow us to do a bunch of
you know kind of in the moment rights
and key updates because keep in mind
like I said the issue before is that we
had to overwrite an entire file and what
hbase is going to do is use an
intelligent architecture to make sure
that we can actually make edits in the
moment we do so via LSM trees which is a
type of database index that we've
discussed plenty on this channel but I
will do a quick overcap or rather recap
on the next slide and then additionally
we can also do a lot of batch processing
due to the data locality that hbase
gives us it does this via using column
oriented storage we've also discussed
this in the past and also range-based
partitioning which keeps data with
similar Keys close together on the same
partition
so let's quickly talk about the hbase
data model because fundamentally it's
very similar to Cassandra but in reality
these two databases should be used for
generally different things so again it's
going to be a wide key column store
which if you can think about it means
that we are in fact using a nosql
database here and again that is similar
to Cassandra in the sense that every row
has to have a certain part of
information and then you've got all this
other stuff that is pretty much just
optional and you know you can either
have it or you don't have to have it but
we do need certain parts of the row that
comprise something known as our Roki and
our row key is basically what determines
in hbase how things are getting
partitioned and also the order in which
they're stored like I mentioned
everything is done by range based
partitioning so we're not taking the
hash of this key we're literally just
partitioning the data right down the
segment as if it were ordered now of
course you could be smart about this and
like literally take what would have been
your row key and just like put in the
hash of that part over there and then
that effectively becomes hash based
partitioning but my point is out of the
box you know it's range based
partitioning and we'll see why that's
good in a little bit at least for the
use case that we want so let's start
talking about architecture because
that's really what sets hbase apart and
as I mentioned it is built on top of
Hadoop so we've got this master node
right here and if you've watched our
Hadoop video that's very similar to the
concept of the name node where we have
this one centralized place which is
effectively just a metadata store and
keeps in memory where all of the files
that we care about are located where
their replicas are what versions We have
etc etc so basically we've got our
client over here on the top left and
whenever a client wants to perform a
right to hbase which is what's important
it basically goes to the master node and
says Where do we want to write to the
master node will then respond with right
to node two so in this case node 2 would
effectively be the partition that the
client should be writing to and then the
client is going to execute that right
over here to node 2. now you may see
that on each of these nodes imagine that
each of these big boxes is one single
computer in our Hadoop cluster
we have two boxes within that a region
node and a data node so the data node
is actually a term that we've discussed
in our Hadoop video and the region node
is hbase and that the region node is
going to be a separate process from hdfs
running in memory likely on the same
computer as the data node then of course
we've got all of our high availability
stuff over here I
availability
because of course if the master node
goes down we don't want to have the
entire system go down so what we
typically will do is we'll send all of
the operations that are occurring on the
masternode over to zookeeper which then
can be read by a secondary masternode so
if the master were to go down the
secondary can take over
so again we now have this concept of a
region node and a data node and keep in
mind that our rights are being sent to a
specific region node let's go ahead and
zoom in on that and learn a little bit
more
so when we examine our region node
what's actually happening well basically
the region node is what is operating our
LSM tree index so let's again discuss
this we've got a client
and to recall the client is going to be
writing to the region node and the
region node in memory is going to be
holding this guy right here which is an
LSM tree so if we recall an LSM tree and
SS table is a type of database index
whereby you write to an in-memory binary
search stream and then when that tree
gets too big we flush all of the data
out to an SS table
which is basically the data in the LSM
tree but sorted and that's held on hard
drive so HDD
and so basically what will happen is
once this LSM Tree on the region node
gets too big you can see that we're
going to go ahead and flush it to an SS
table on disk on the data node so keep
in mind that the data node is part of
Hadoop right it's part of hdfs and what
happens to things that get sent as files
to Hadoop they get replicated how do
they get replicated through the
replication pipeline now if you remember
from last video what that basically
means is that we've got one data node
sending a right to another data node
which sends a right to another data node
and then you pass the chain of
acknowledgments all the way back through
to the original data node and eventually
you know it gets propagated over to the
name node which then updates its
metadata store and so that's exactly how
hbase is going to do things as well
basically all of the SS tables that are
eventually flushed to hdfs are going to
be replicated through that replication
Pipeline and that is how we make sure
that we have fault tolerance in our data
of course we also have something like a
write ahead log on our region node to
make sure that our LSM tree doesn't get
lost if the region node were to crash or
something like that but generally
speaking the point here is that we have
hbase which kind of manages our LSM
trees and then hdfs which is going to
manage the replication of our SS tables
and then additionally hbase is going to
be managing our partitioning and
effectively every single region node is
going to be a different partition and so
as you can see this guy would have a
separate
lsmetry
which is then going to flush separate SS
tables
and those can be replicated however
Hadoop sees fit to either this node or
to this node down here the point is we
can think of the replication part as a
black box Hadoop is taking care of that
for us
okay so another key aspect of hbase that
is super useful is that it uses column
oriented storage now we've spoken about
this a decent amount in the past
especially when it comes to park it
which is an open source way of kind of
Performing column oriented storage
Market files or a type of file but
basically just to reiterate on the
difference we've got row oriented
storage which basically has every single
row of data next to one another on disk
and then differently we have column
oriented storage where we take every
single column and we put those next to
one another on disk so this would be the
name column
and then below it we would have all of
the rows in the same order for the
attractiveness column
and so what that allows us to do is say
we want to perform an analytical query
over the attractiveness column where we
say okay well what's the mean
attractiveness over this data set
instead of having to pull in all of that
name data we can cancel that out just
pull in the attractiveness data and then
say oh well it's 10 plus 5 plus 2 plus 1
over 4 which is 18 over 4 which is 4.5
whatever it doesn't really matter
but even better than that is assuming we
are using parkit here for our column
oriented storage we could actually store
some general stats of the column which
is kind of nice we can cache those so we
could have things like the Min the max
of the column or and even the average in
general so that would be useful for us
and of course if these column values are
super similar as well we can perform
some column compression to basically
just speed up our queries and also
minimize the amount of data on disk that
we're taking up so just in general the
kind of gist of column oriented storage
is this right here which is that it is
better for analytics queries because we
have better data locality and in
addition to that that makes it better
for batch processes as well because it
means that all of the data that we want
is closer to one another on disk it
means that we have to send less data
over the network there's less
coordination that has to be done when
kind of aggregating and organizing the
data and sorting it and so as a result
hbase allows us to organize our data in
a way that is really really good for
these batch processes without having to
sacrifice the fact that you know making
an individual right to a piece of the
data requires an entire file overwrite
which is super expensive additionally
besides the column oriented storage part
we're also using range-based
partitioning and so imagine you know
we partition data this way right here
this can be really nice because let's
say we're handling timestamp data or
something and we wanted to do a batch
query that let's say calculated like a
trailing average of the last five data
points if we were using hash range based
partitioning all of our time stamps
would probably be on different nodes
organized pretty randomly but when we
use range based partitioning it means
that all of the timestamps that are
similar to one another are going to be
on the same node and again that just
means passing less data over the network
and we can perform our computations a
little bit quicker that's kind of a
niche thing but
even still it doesn't really hurt for
this type of thing okay so what is the
conclusion of hbase well generally
speaking we probably don't want to be
using it just for a normal client-facing
application right because at the end of
the day if we just want to perform a
bunch of Rights and then read from the
partition that we've just written to we
don't really need hbase for that we can
use something like Cassandra where we're
still getting all of the benefits of the
LSM tree for rights we have leaderless
replication to write and read from even
faster and just in general you know we
don't necessarily need column oriented
storage because generally speaking we
just want to fetch one row at a time and
probably all of the values of that one
row and so row oriented storage happens
to be better in that case but on the
other hand if we kind of want a wrapper
around hdfs which gives us the freedom
to still do normal database operations
while also having the ability to perform
big batch computations then age base
might be a better system for us this
could be really useful for things like
and sensor readings just general data
points that we may have to modify down
the line where we're not just writing
them once and then reading them back in
the future and so as a result of that
keep hbase in mind when you see a use
case like this I imagine it probably
won't come up too much during the
system's design interview just because I
don't know it's kind of a nuanced system
and a lot of the things that we're doing
in the interview probably aren't getting
that in depth but even still I think
it's important to understand why hbase
exists in the first place how it's a big
improvement over something like Hadoop
and how also it falls short of something
like Cassandra when it comes to just
typical reads and writes for your normal
client-side application anyways guys I
hope you have a great day hope the video
was informative and I will see you in
the next one